..because that is when,
unfortunately...
Species A is worth 50 bucks
and species B
is worth $10,000.
Biodiversity is declining
in such a rapid rate.
I find that terrifying.
But what is driving the biggest
changes today is...
One solution to this problem...
...because, unfortunately,
in the world we live in...
Can these very tools
that drive
the decline of nature
be the tools that help us
reverse the process?
Humans emerged from nature.
We're part of the biosphere.
It is really important for our
physical and mental wellbeing.
I think it's useful
to think about an ecosystem,
and whether an ecosystem
destroyed or harvested
is worth more or less
than an ecosystem intact.
In many cases, there is more
value in that ecosystem and...
One of the really big issues,
I think,
with valuing nature is,
how do you do it?
When you cut down a tree
and you sell it as timber,
you're able to realise
the market value
of that timber.
Whereas if that tree
still remains in a forest,
it's playing a lot
of functional roles,
for surrounding communities
and even the global community.
Look at these lovely plants!
One really interesting question
is...
The question has
an obvious answer.
The Amazon rainforest is
the centre of biodiversity
on planet Earth -
there's no way that is worth
less than a company.
So if we started, for example,
by looking at the carbon value
in terms of climate change
mitigation,
the rainfall
that's being generated
by that rainforest existing,
the biodiversity that provides
lots of interactions
around pollination
and controlling pests,
that may one day provide
medical benefits for people.
And then on top of that,
that rainforest is ancient.
It's been around
for 60 million years.
And that has intrinsic
respect and value
that we also need
to consider in the equation.
Viewing nature as an asset,
rather than a commodity,
is absolutely essential,
because an asset you always
want to build on,
you want to enhance,
and you want to protect.
One of the big arguments
is that
it doesn't recognise
the intrinsic relationships
that people have with nature.
And none of those can be
properly represented with...
We cannot depend
upon pricing of nature
as the solution to problems
because....
I mean, the danger
with putting a price on nature
is that you create incentives
for people
to cheapen nature, because they
want to make money off of it.
Communities that live
close to nature,
and are dependent
on nature directly,
are often the poorest.
As a consequence,
given their low incomes,
the economic value
of what they get from nature,
the positive benefits that they
get, turns out to be very low.
..living close to nature,
but in poverty,
and therefore eliminating
their voices
from the decision-making
system.
In the state of California,
if you're a developer,
you want to build
a bunch of houses,
you know that
your new housing complex
is going to kill off breeding
pairs of burrowing owls.
You need to account for those
burrowing owls someplace else.
And so you have to then say,
"I'm willing to pay $2,000
for a burrowing owl.
Who out there can conserve
a burrowing owl
for $2,000 for me?
Because that's the budget
that I have."
One of the pioneering examples
of bringing nature
into decision-making
was the country
of Costa Rica...
Which has gone from
predominately deforestation
to reforestation.
So Costa Rica now,
by most metrics,
has the highest
Human Development Index,
is the most prosperous
and developed of the countries
of its neighbourhood.
...let alone the wellbeing
of nature
that could sustain
human wellbeing over time.
Rethinking
the fundamental structure
of what's a good economy,
a good nation, a good life
is a fundamental part
of what we need to do.
There's not one silver bullet
here,
but I think this approach
of valuing nature
is an important one.
In some ways,
it is like that discussion
between idealists
and pragmatists.
Some people feel we should not
be putting a price on nature,
and ethically,
it's not right to do it.
All of us have
that idealist part in us.
But we also have to be
entirely pragmatic.
We need a blueprint for nature
that says
these parts of the globe
are the most important
for nature,
and we absolutely
must protect them.
Putting a price on nature
is one way to value.
It is not the only way
to value nature.
And so if we just recognise
that monetary valuation
is but one of a suite of ways,
that would go a long way.